with Avengers infinity war the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is heading towards a
conflict that's been building for nearly
a decade
Thanos has been on a collision course
with the rest of the heroes since 2012
Avengers and he's finally taking center
stage in a battle for the Infinity
stones the war will unite an entire
universe of superheroes but it will also
likely have lethal consequences given
the stakes involved and the mad Titan
status as the ultimate bad guy of the
Marvel movies the question is an if one
of the heroes would make it out alive
but which one let's take a look at the
cast of infinity war to come up with our
best betting odds on which heroes might
not make it to the closing credits watch
out for potential spoilers as we figure
out who's going to meet their maker and
we don't mean Stan Lee are you dank
Black Panther the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has doled out more than its
share of jaw-dropping surprises over the
last decade and the studio's brain trust
has proven itself more than willing to
take bold creative risks with the
franchise's storytelling but Marvel
Studios also has to consider its bottom
line and since Black Panther just became
one of the highest-grossing superhero
movies of all time there's no way the
executives are going to let him get away
that easily forget about his vibranium
stockpile pulling in that much money at
the theater is what really makes the
charla bulletproof there's just no way
we can just king isn't one of the heroes
left standing once infinity war is over
odds 1.23 9 billion and Counting - 1
spider-man also far too promising for
dismantlement right now is spider-man
granted Peter Parker is going to be
completely outmatched against Thanos and
seems to be primed to suffer some
serious punishment in the movie but with
a second spider-man homecoming movie
during theaters next year the chances of
him being truly taken out by Thanos seem
SLAM he's just way too new and too
popular to meet his end just yet
odds 100 to 1 Himura
she's a deadliest woman in the galaxy
and she's got a major grudge against
Thanos who basically stole her from her
home planet and tortured her adopted
sister Gomorrah might've been Thanos his
favorite daughter growing up but she
doesn't seem to have much love for the
mad Titan now it seems more likely that
should be the one to take down Thanos
then that he'd ever get to lay his
purple hands on her after all she
learned from him odds seventy five to
one lakh widow fans have been clamoring
for Black Widow to get a solo movie
since she first kicked her way into the
screen in Iron Man 2 so getting rid of
her before we actually get to see her
stand alone seems like a
catastrophically bad idea that said
natasha romanoff a to join the infinity
war saga could go either way if it's a
backstory that people really want to see
it doesn't matter much that she survives
in the current timeline right with Hulk
Captain America and the black panther I
decide though she's probably still got a
good shot of hanging in there this time
odds 50 to 1 hole on one level
Hulk is arguably the easiest character
to get rid of in infinity war he hasn't
had a solo movie since 2008 sin credible
Hulk and he's kind of a liability for
the Avengers anyway with Marvel's
seeming pretty and interested in giving
the Hulk of solar spotlights there's a
strong possibility that his part in the
franchise might be coming to an end
it's also worth noting that Mark Ruffalo
revealed that the plan has been to give
the Hulk an arc that would begin in Thor
Ragnarok and continue through the -
infinity war movies in Ragnarok Bruce
became the Hulk for years at a time
which allowed the green guy to run the
show without banners knowledge or
approval it's easy to see how that loss
of control might not work out so well
for him then isn't it odds 20 to 1 Thor
Thor Ragnarok was funny but it also put
Thor through the wringer his hammer was
shattered he lost an eye and his
homeland of Asgard was destroyed leaving
him exiled in outer space if the plan is
for things to keep getting worse for the
Odinson then there's really not a whole
lot left to do with them but plant him
under a tombstone but with so much
coming down on him in his own movie Thor
seems to be gaining strength he's now
able to channel his supernatural gifts
and he's expected to get a new hammer in
infinity war called the storm breaker so
it seems just as likely that the god of
thunders luck will turn around in the
film as it does that it encountered ease
or himself odds 15 to 1
Drax of all the guardians of the galaxy
Drax seems like he might be the most
likely choice for the chopping block in
the comics his entire reason for living
is to execute Thanos since the movie
version tends to launch himself into
battle without thinking of any
consequences his fast fury could lead to
a toe to toe fight with the deadliest
being the Marvel Universe has to offer
if that is in fact what happens it's
pretty hard to imagine drugs coming out
as the winner at the same time dave
Batista's performance and the guardians
movies have made him a fan favorite so
the question is whether the shock value
of having him take one for the team is
enough to outweigh the benefits of
keeping him around odds 12 to 1
Hawkeye even before he was curiously
absent from the film's character happy
poster Hawkeye hasn't been the most
obvious priority for Marvel Studios and
his art reflects that he's retired
gotten bored enough to join Captain
America's illegal strike force and being
imprisoned as a war criminal by Iron Man
those are all pretty good signs that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe doesn't have
much left to do with the archer beyond
giving him a noble death to let everyone
else know the states in the war against
Thanos
let's be real for a second though if
they did kill a four kind infinity war
would you actually even notice odds
ten-to-one star-lord another hero who
seems unlikely to die the hands of a mad
Titan his Peter Quayle after all he's
already survived a couple of cosmic
threats before so what's one more plus
Chris Pratt schematic shops have set the
tone that the guardians movies are built
on and that seems to be carrying through
to an infinity war as well I think it's
good except it sucks so let me do the
plan on the other hand the star Lords
death would be a huge shock which might
mean it'd be worth it just for the sake
of keeping audiences on their toes
besides he's half Living Planet
and as we all saw in guardians 2 it
takes more than a couple of blaster
balls to the head to take one of them
out permanently
nobody ever said these characters have
to stay dead to make your own to Thanos
his kill count for this film odds
ten-to-one Doctor Strange
as the sorcerer supreme dr. strange is
the only one who's faced a kind of
celestial threat Thanos represents
taking on Dormammu by himself and coming
away with a victory with that kind of
win on his record it seems likely that
strangers formal introduction to the
Avengers could be the thing that tips
odds in their favor who's laughing now
but his future in the MCU is
questionable at the moment since even
Benedict Cumberbatch doesn't seem to
know whether Doctor Strange - is gonna
actually happen the filmmakers did
already sets up Baron Mordo as a villain
for his next outing but we'll have to
wait and see whether that pays off or if
the mystic meets his end an infinity war
instead odds aides Awana vision he saved
the day in age of Ultron but since then
the visions had a pretty hard time
fitting into his role as an Avenger in
civil war he couldn't even stop Hawkeye
and Scarlet Witch from walking out of a
room and the misfired laser beam wound
up permanently injuring war machine one
of his own teammates with that kind of
track record it's tough to imagine him
lasting long in a fight against Thanos
moreover a vision has one of the
Infinity stones mounted on his forehead
and from the film's previews it looks
like Ferris has minion Corvus glaive
might just get to him before it's all
said and done suffice it to say things
aren't looking good for the Avengers
resident synthezoid odds 5 to 1 nebula
it's no secret that infinity war is
drawing pretty heavily from the events
of 1991 s Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and in that story
Thanos keeps nebula suspended just on
the verge of death as a form of torture
to amuse himself the twist is that
nebula is ultimately able to get control
of the Infinity stones herself which
sets into motion phalluses defeat since
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 spend so
much time patching up nebulas
relationship with Gamora and
establishing that Thanos is no stranger
to mutilating her just for kicks
having Thanos target as renegade dorsa
would be an easy way to show moviegoers
hold ruthless he can be or she could end
up being one of the people who helps
take him down in the end as it was
written we'll have to wait and see odds
5 to 1 Captain America Steve Rogers is
easily the most beloved of the Avengers
so if the film's producers really wants
to hit the audiences with the gut punch
killing off Captain America would do it
what better way to reunite the Avengers
after the events of Civil War than
having them rally around his heroic
sacrifice the previews certainly seemed
to be setting the tone for a tough fight
between cap and Thanos and Chris Evans
himself has confirmed that he intends to
retire from blockbuster movies in favor
of smaller films it hardly seems like a
coincidence that Steve Rogers has not
one but two characters I could take up a
shield if he falls in battle Falcon and
Bucky Barnes Evans has mentioned that
he's still set to appear in the movie
that comes after infinity war but
there's nothing that says our parents
won't be in a flashback or a coffin odds
3 2 1
Iron Man Tony Stark we don't know for
sure of course but it looks like Tony
Stark is not going to survive this movie
Wow it might actually be the only
logical conclusion to a character Wright
has been building since 2000 and dates
over the past few movies Tony's fears
about the changing world and his efforts
to get ahead of the disasters that come
from a world full of superheroes and
villains have gone increasingly off the
rails his attempt to create artificial
intelligence and least Ultron and
resulted in the complete destruction of
sokovia which in turn led directly to
the Avengers themselves being destroyed
as a team during the events of civil war
even his most recent protégé Peter
Parker was defined by his choice to
reject the path that Tony took as Iron
Man with a conflict that's bigger and
more far-reaching than anything he's
dealt with before the consequences are
going to be just as huge and for Tony
that likely means a heroic sacrifice
there's a certain poetry to it I a man
was the movie that kicked off the MCU in
2008 and what better way to mark the
10th anniversary of the cinematic
universe than by killing off its
founding character it'd be bittersweet
of course but it'd be the best farewell
I a man could hope for to sacrifice
himself for the sake of the planet and
the universe at large
Tommy's name again ODS 3 to 2 in other
words
rest in peace Iron Man thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]